[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers
guten Abend in allen es gab keine
Warnung und keine offizielle Begründung
aber plötzlich waren die Twitter konnten
von mehreren prominenten Journalisten
gesperrt die Kolleginnen und Kollegen
unter anderem von New York Times und CNN
hatten kritisch berichtet über
twitter-chef Elon Musk seit er die
Kommunikationsplattform übernommen hat
haben mehr als zwei Drittel der
Angestellten gekündigt oder wurden
gefeuert ganze Abteilungen die etwa
illegale Tweets löschen sollten
existieren nur noch auf dem Papier was
geht und was nicht geht auf Twitter
entscheidet jetzt Milliardär mask
alleine und erateisch
das alles ist auch deshalb relevant weil
Twitter wie kein anderes Netzwerk zur
Plattform von Medien Regierungen und
Organisationen weltweit geworden ist die
sich jetzt alle überlegen müssen ob sie
noch dabei bleiben können wenn ihr mit
Daniel mit mehr
ihr Account wurde permanent gesperrt
diese Nachricht erhält der bekannte
cnn-journalist Donnie O'Sullivan als er
sich gestern Abend bei Twitter einloggen
will mask wirft ihm und anderen
Journalisten vor sie hätten seinen Live
Standort gepostet
es gibt einen Twitter-Account der
öffentlich zugängliche Daten nutzt um
das Privatflugzeug von Elon Musk zu
tracken diesen Account hat mask sperren
lassen und eigens dafür die
twitter-regeln geändert und darüber
haben wir Journalisten berichtet also
dass dieser Account deaktiviert wurde
und dann schrieb mich gestern Abend
gegen sieben mein Kollege Oliver darf
sie an und meinte hey du wurdest gerade
selbst bei Twitter gesperrt
sowie aus Hallein ist es zahlreichen
US-Journalisten ergangen die Musk
offenbar grundlos hat sperren lassen zur
Erinnerung so klang seine Worte kurz
bevor er die Plattform übernahm
ich denke Twitter sollte eine Arena der
freien Rede sein wenn jemand den du
nicht magst etwas sagen kann das dir
nicht gefällt wenn das der Fall ist dann
ist das Redefreiheit
das ausgerechnet einer der vordersten
Kämpfer für radikale Redefreiheit eben
jene einschränkt empört auch das
deutsche Außenministerium in dessen
Tweet heißt es heute Pressefreiheit darf
nicht nach Belieben ein und
ausgeschaltet werden
eingeschaltet lässt mask auf jeden Fall
seine eigene Redefreiheit so verbreitet
er unter anderem verschwörungsmythen
Wetter gegen die Wissenschaft und räumt
Rassisten und Antisemiten die Rückkehr
auf die Plattform ein
masks unberechenbare Art wirkt sich auch
negativ auf den Aktienkurs seiner
anderen riesenfirma Tesla aus und seine
Egozentrik schreckt nicht nur Investoren
ab auch immer mehr Nutzer kehren der
Plattform den Rücken
da gibt es keine durchgedachte
Entscheidungsfindung sondern nur eine
Machtkonzentration bei der Entscheidung
was Meinungsfreiheit ist es braucht ein
unabhängiges Gremium nicht nur Elon Musk
der entscheidet welche konnten
suspendiert und welche zugelassen werden
ebenfalls im Alleingang feuert mask
weiterhin Angestellte wie diese 48
Hausmeister die gegen ihre Entlassung
protestieren sie hatten während der
Pandemie maßgeblichen Anteil daran dass
der Laden überhaupt weiterlaufen konnte
gegen die neue Gefahr von oben die das
Unternehmen zum Banken bringt konnten
sie nichts ausrichten
die Europäische Union droht mask und
Twitter jetzt mit Sanktionen dazu ist
Julian jauersch bei uns erforscht zum
Thema Umgang mit Desinformation und
Regulierung von tech-plattformen bei der
gemeinnützigen Stiftung neue
Verantwortung in Berlin Herr Josch guten
Abend guten Abend wie hat man sich das
denn aktuell vorzustellen da macht einer
quasi nach gut herrenart die Regeln
jeden Tag neu und entscheidet selbst wer
dabei bleibt und wer rausfliegt ja so
sieht's aktuell aus es ist ja nicht nur
irgendwie die die Sperrung von
bestimmten Konten es ist die Auflösung
eines freiwilligen beratungscreme
Gremiums ist es nicht gezahlte Miete es
ist Inhalte Moderation und
Sicherheitsinfrastruktur die gerade
nicht mehr gewartet wird also es scheint
tatsächlich ziemlich chaotisch zu sein
aktuell in bestimmten Teilen des
Unternehmens dagegen kann man jetzt
nicht unbedingt als Gesetzgeber oder als
EU was machen aber man kann zumindest
dafür sorgen dass Transparenz und
Sicherheit für die Nutzenden weit
sichergestellt wird bevor wir darüber
gleich reden was jetzt zu tun wäre würde
ich gerne noch einen Aspekt mit
reinbringen den man ja auch manchmal
hört der Laden gehört ihm nun mal also
warum sollte er das nicht tun
er kann es tun also das steht glaube ich
dass das stellt ihm auch keine ab dass
es Privatmann ist der der mit seinem
Unternehmen machen kann was er will ich
glaube was die Leute stört und was wir
hier auch sehen an diesem sehr hohen
Transparenz die wir gerade haben in
dieser Diskussion dass manche Leute das
halt nicht gefällt und dass er als
Geschäftsmann als Unternehmer halt auch
gucken muss welche Entscheidung seinem
Unternehmen gut tun und welche nicht
Leute auch das Unternehmen verlassen
richtig und das ist eben nicht irgendein
Unternehmen das muss man vielleicht auch
mal klar machen das werden wir gleich
auch noch besprechen jetzt sagt die EU
Kommissarin heute eine EU-Kommissarin
sagt heute es gibt rote Linien und in
der Tat ab Februar 2024 soll ein Gesetz
über digitale Dienste in der gesamten EU
gelten was kann denn die Europäische
Union jetzt schon machen
dieses angesprochene digitale Dienste
gesetzt der EU und der Digital Service
Eck das ist tatsächlich das worauf jetzt
alle warten in Brüssel und in der
gesamten EU weil das gerade erst
verabschiedet wurde und ab dem kommenden
Jahr wirksam sein wird da wird es glaube
ich viele Möglichkeiten geben
einzuwirken aktuell gibt es eher auf
nationaler Ebene Möglichkeiten gegenüber
großen Plattformen aktiv zu werden aber
die sind eben noch nicht ganz so
ausgereift und ich glaube der dass
digital dienstgesetz ist wirklich das wo
wo wir es ähm europäische BürgerInnen
drauf gucken muss und wäre das dann
tatsächlich auch gekoppelt mit ich sage
das mal mit Bußgeldern mit Bußgeldern in
auch ansprechender Höhe so dass selbst
ein Multimilliardär sagt oh da muss ich
mich jetzt dran halten ja ist es ähm es
gibt Bußgelder und die sind auch nicht
zu knapp bemessen das bemisst sich am
ähm Jahresumsatzes Unternehmens das kann
empfindlich sein ich würde aber gar
nicht so sehr auf die Bußgelder schielen
ehrlich gesagt das ist auch eher später
im Prozess was viel wichtiger ist dass
die Europäische Kommission aber das auch
unabhängige Behörden in den
Mitgliedstaaten vorher darauf auf die
Plattform einwirken können dass sie ihre
rechenschaftspflichten ihre
Transparenzpflichten einhalten das also
darüber viel mehr nutzen geschaffen wird
und Sicherheit für die Menschen
geschaffen wird als nur in
Anführungsstrichen ein Bußgeld aber ja
ein Bußgeld ist auch möglich jetzt gibt
es sicherlich Menschen die sagen twitter
ist mir egal andererseits ist es aber
eben auch für viele mit vielen Followern
eine Geschäftsgrundlage unentbehrliches
Forum Nachrichtenbörse praktisch
sämtliche Staatschefin Staatschefs
weltweit sind auf Twitter unterwegs
können die alle noch weiter auf Twitter
setzen was würden Sie beispielsweise den
Bundeskanzler warten
ich glaube hier bei den Plattformen muss
man unterscheiden ob wir jetzt reden von
einer Plattform die irgendwie ein
Mikrofon ist ein ein Megafon für Leute
das ist das sind glaube ich die Accounts
die Menschen die sie angesprochen haben
oder ob es sich darum handelt dass es
wirklich so eine Art Plattform für den
Austausch zwischen Privatleuten sein
soll und Twitter war lange Zeit beides
hat sich dann aber eher zu dieser
Megafon artigen Plattform entwickelt und
für diese Leute ist es glaube ich sehr
sinnvoll zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt
hinterfragen möchte ich auf dieser
Plattform nicht sein oder kann ich nicht
auch
anderweitig meine Meinung Positionen
Kommentare unterbringen anderweitig wo
es gibt unterschiedliche Möglichkeiten
einerseits könnte man sich überlegen auf
dezentralen Netzwerke auszuweichen die
es jetzt schon die jetzt schon
existieren es ist auch möglich über
Newsletter eigene Plattform Webseiten
Leute zu erreichen es ist auch nicht
auszuschließen dass Alternativen zu
Twitter zentrale Alternativen zu Twitter
entstehen die vielleicht Elemente von
Twitter haben und zu guter Letzt würde
ich auch nicht ausschließen dass Twitter
in dieser Form oder in der leicht
abgewandelform auch überlebt auch das
ist glaube ich nicht auszuschließen und
dass wir auch dort weiterhin Staatschefs
und Staatschefin werden
die Zukunft von Twitter oder eben eine
Zukunft ohne Twitter Julian Jauer
herzlichen Dank für das Gespräch
herzlichen Dank
und das Gespräch haben wir vor einer
Stunde aufgezeichnet aus den Pipelines
kommt nichts mehr aus Russland die
beiden nordstream-röhren liegen zwar
noch auf dem Grund der Ostsee sind aber
nach dem Anschlag Ende September
unbrauchbar und dennoch verkauft
Vladimir Putin sein Gas weiter und
weiter auch an Europa die Importe von
russischem flüssig Erdgas nämlich sind
auf einen neuen Höchststand gestiegen
die Gesamtmenge ist nur ein Bruchteil
des bisherigen pipeline-gases aber sie
dürfte weiter steigen denn auch
Deutschland setzt ja voll auf flüssiges
Erdgas das erste deutsche lng-terminal
ist jetzt startklar peter Kurz
Esperanza Hoffnung heißt die schwimmende
regersifizierungsanlage die gestern in
Wilhelmshaven einlief Herzstück des in
Rekordzeit gebauten ersten deutschen
flüssig-terminals und Hoffnung auf
Unabhängigkeit von russischen Gas
Deutschland setzt neben den eigenen
Terminal Projekten auf das vorhandene
Netz von flüssiggasanschlüssen in
europäischen Häfen wir haben an den
westeuropäischen Küsten mit unseren
Freunden gesprochen in den Niederlanden
in Belgien dass sie die Terminals
ausbauen und die Leitungskapazität mit
Frankreich dass das erste mal Gas zu uns
liefern wird LNG verflüssigtes Gas aus
allen Himmelsrichtungen aber leider auch
wieder aus Russland denn die Importe von
russischen flüssig Erdgas nach Europa
sind in den letzten Monaten auf einen
Rekordwert gestiegen 13% des
eingekauften LG stammen aus Russland wir
haben eine Erhöhung der Flüssigkeit
Importe von Russland nach Europa die
gehen insbesondere nach Spanien und
Frankreich dort gibt es nämlich
Langfristverträge zwischen den Ländern
und Russland aber es kommt auch ein Teil
neuerdings nach Belgien und Niederlande
und da dieses Glas wird dann noch weiter
geliefert nach Deutschland auch der
Verband europäischer Energiehändler
bestätigt den ZDF wir gehen generell
davon aus dass russisches Gas über
Drittstaaten doch wieder in die EU
gelangen könnte das lässt sich am Port
einfach nicht voneinander trennen
westsibirisches Gas kommt jetzt übers
Meer auch über in den letzten Monaten
neu gebaute russische lng-terminals
geringere Mengen zwar als bisher
exportiert wurden aber dafür verdient
Putin am teuren LG 5 bis 10 Mal so viel
wie vorher zum Beispiel Anlieferungen
über die Nord Stream Pipeline und
niemand redet von einem gasboykott
gegenüber Russland und solange der
russische Gas irgendwo in dem Weltmarkt
verfügbar bleibt es ist nur so ein Spiel
wenn alle auf russisches Glas verzichten
kann vielen irgendwo 20 Milliarden
Kubikmeter die man irgendwoher
beschaffen muss und es wird im Zweifel
sein nur mit Anbieter zu steigenden
Preisen führen der Markt grenzt Russland
nicht aus französische Firmen sind zum
Beispiel an flüssig Erdgas Joint
Ventures mit der russischen Firma
novatec beteiligt
Zwischenhändler Zwischenlagerung am Ende
hat LNG keine Nationalität sondern nur
Moleküle grundsätzlich ist er das
lng-geschäft eben einen Geschäft wo
weltweit Gas gehandelt wird aus
verschiedensten Quellen wir als als
Juniper haben wir seit Anfang des Jahres
schon uns entschieden kann zusätzliches
russisches Gas ins Portfolio zu holen
und das wird auch so bleiben Juniper
will Deutschlands erstes flüssig erdgast
Terminal tatsächlich unabhängig von
russischen Lieferungen betreiben
Esperanza die Hoffnung denn ein Fair
Trade Siegel gibt es im internationalen
Gasgeschäft nicht
und der Blick jetzt auf die weitere
Nachrichtenlage an diesem Freitag mit
dir Hanna Whistleblower die auf
Missstände in Behörden oder Unternehmen
hinweisen sollen besser geschützt werden
das hat der Bundestag beschlossen Firmen
mit mehr als 50 Mitarbeiterinnen und
Mitarbeitern müssen künftig interne
Meldestellen einrichten gleiches gilt
für Behörden zudem sieht das Gesetz eine
externe Anlaufstelle beim Bundesamt für
Justiz vor die Opposition kritisierte
unter anderem den hohen bürokratischen
Aufwand des Vorhabens
für den Bundesrat gab es heute in der
letzten Sitzung dieses Jahres einiges zu
tun die Länderkammer billigte insgesamt
31 Gesetze darunter unter anderem
Vorhaben die die gestiegenen
Energiepreise abfedern sollen so ist die
Gas und strompreisbremse nun
beschlossene Sache gleiches gilt für die
energiepauschale von 200 Euro für
Studierende auch dem Handelsabkommen
ceta mit Kanada hat der Bundesrat
zugestimmt genauso wie einer Vielzahl
steuerlicher Änderungen zum Beispiel zur
Erbschaftssteuer
die Ermittlungsbehörden haben drei
Darknet Plattformen abgeschaltet auf
denen Videos und Fotos von
sexualisierter Gewalt gegen Kinder
verbreitet wurden laut den Ermittlern
gehörten sie mit 100 gehört sie gehörten
sie mit hunderttausenden Nutzern zu den
weltweit größten Plattformen drei Männer
wurden in Deutschland festgenommen
darunter auch der mutmaßliche
hauptadministrator ein 21-jähriger Mann
aus Sachsen
der ukrainische Präsident selenski und
das ukrainische Volk sind mit dem
Karlspreis 2023 für Verdienste um Europa
ausgezeichnet worden gemeinsam
verteidigten sie nicht nur die
Souveränität der Ukraine sondern auch
Europa und europäische Werte hieß es in
der Begründung mit der Verleihung wolle
das Direktorium unterstreichen dass das
Land Teil Europas sei
unterdessen erlebten die Menschen in der
Ukraine heute eine weitere große
Angriffswelle von über 70 russischen
Raketen Marschflugkörpern und Drohnen
seit zwar der größte Teil abgefangen
worden so dass ukrainische Militär doch
durch die Schäden an der Energie
Infrastruktur gab es landesweit
Stromabschaltungen und Ausfälle auch in
den u-bahn-schutzräumen der Hauptstadt
die besonders von den Angriffen ins
Visier genommen wurden in privi traf
eine Rakete ein Wohngebäude mindestens
zwei Menschen wurden getötet 13 verletzt
ja sind die täglichen horror-meldungen
aus einem Krieg der nun seit zehn
Monaten die Menschen terrorisiert und
kein Ende in Sicht und gleichzeitig gibt
es jeden Tag neue Geschichten von
mutigen Ukrainerinnen und Ukrainern
heute abend hat in Berlin ein
eindrucksvoller dokumentarfilmpremiere
der sechs Frauen begleitet die für ihre
Heimat stehen wie ein Fels in der
Brandung christa-läpple
[Musik]
Schwester Frauen in der Ukraine endlich
können sie ihre Geschichten erzählen
auch wenn das Sprechen so schwer fällt
die Filme Macherin anna copylova ist
selbst in großer Sorge ihre beiden
Kinder sind in Kiew sie ist zur Premiere
in Berlin heute war wieder ein
Raketenangriff meine Kinder waren heute
morgen im Bunker ich bin wirklich
gestresst weil ich hier bin ich bin
nicht so nervös wenn ich in Kiew bin
hier in diesem friedlichen Umfeld mit
Weihnachtsmarkt und so das ist richtiger
Stress für mich
die Dokumentarfilmerin hat im Juni 2022
eine Delegation von drei
nobelpreisträgerinnen in die Ukraine
begleitet sie erzählt von einem Land mit
viel Leid aber auch unbeugsamen Frauen
vom Fenster aus konnte ich sehen wie
meine Nachbarn evakuiert wurden Männer
Frauen und Kinder stiegen in die Autos
jeder Rand und war aufgeregt an diesem
Abend entschied ich mich in die Armee zu
gehen
das ist eine Haubitze 152 mm oder irgend
so etwas
die 24-Jährige Sanitäterin riskiert
täglich ihr Leben auch Tata und der
Front als Apothekerin
[Musik]
sie brechen den Mädchen die Handgelenke
damit sie sich nicht wehren können um
sie immer wieder auch in der Gruppe zu
vergewaltigen und sie überlassen die
Frauen ihrem Schicksal absichtlich aber
es ist nicht das Regime es sind die
Menschen die das tun
ich glaube das ist eine der brutalsten
Waffen die eingesetzt wird gegen die
Frauen indem sie
sexualisierte Gewalt erfahren um ihre
Seele zu töten
Allah leidet eine Hilfsorganisation für
Kinder
ich werde nie vergessen wie ein schwer
verletzter junge später ein Foto
schickte auf dem war ein Bein im Schnee
zu sehen er schrieb das ist das Bein
meiner Mutter mit dem Film Alexandra
matwick unerschrockene Anwältin seit
kurzem Friedensnobelpreisträgerin ihre
Organisation hat bislang 27.000
Kriegsverbrechen dokumentiert
wir sind keine Historiker wir sind
Menschenrechtsanwälte wir dokumentieren
die Verbrechen die im Namen Putins
begangen werden und alle
Verantwortlichen auch die Generäle
müssen zur Rechenschaft gezogen werden
[Musik]
ein bewegender Dokumentarfilm aus der
Ukraine berührend erzählt er Geschichten
von mutigen Frauen
oh sister der Film ist kostenlos bei
Videoplattformen im Netz zu sehen bei
uns jetzt noch mal Hanna die steigenden
Gaspreise haben den Energiekonzern
uniper heftig ins Wanken gebracht der
Bund will das Unternehmen deshalb
verstaatlichen und das darf er auch
entsteht entschied nun die EU-Kommission
fragen wir nach bei Valerie Haller warum
war dieses Jahr aus Brüssel heute so
wichtig ja weil ein Nein das Ende
bedeutet hätte und das sollte man
unbedingt vermeiden uniper ist
Deutschlands größter gasimporteur und
Händler und ein wichtiger Stromproduzent
ein Zusammenbruch hätte auch regionale
Grundversorger in große Schwierigkeiten
gebracht und mit ihnen Millionen
Haushalte und Unternehmen die dann
deutlich mehr für ihr Gas hätten
bezahlen müssen Juniper ist tatsächlich
systemrelevant zu groß um zu fallen seit
Monaten schreibt Juniper täglich
Millionen Verluste selbst Milliarden
schwere Staatshilfen reichten nicht aus
nun wird der Konzern verstaatlich gern
die Aktionäre am Montag zustimmen eine
teure Rettung derzeit geht man davon aus
dass sie den Staat mehr als 30
Milliarden Euro kosten wird ob Juniper
je wieder auf die Beine kommt völlig
ungewiss kaum ein Unternehmen war so
abhängig von russischen Gas wie Juniper
nach dem Lieferstopp musste der Händler
teures Gas am Spotmarkt kaufen um seine
Kunden zu bedienen und das konnte nicht
lange gut gehen damals ist aber trotzdem
noch nicht alles in trockenen Tüchern
oder genau die Kommission muss noch die
staatlichen Beihilfen genehmigen dafür
könnte es Auflagen geben möglicherweise
den Verkauf einzelner Firmen Teile Tafel
Silber vermutlich was eine Erholung
junepass weiter erschweren dürfte danke
Valerie für diese Einschätzungen
Gemeinden können auch noch nach
Jahrzehnten Bauland zurückfordern wenn
der Käufer eine Bauverpflichtung nicht
eingehalten hat das entschied der
Bundesgerichtshof ein Wiederkaufsrecht
kann laut Gesetz bis zu 30 Jahre lang
ausgeübt werden eine bayerische Gemeinde
hatte das nach 20 Jahren gemacht
unangemessen urteilte die Vorinstanz der
BGH widersprach nun es liege im
öffentlichen Interesse das
Bebauungspläne rasch umgesetzt und
Grundstücksspekulationen verhindert
werden
zum Biathlon Weltcup in Frankreich da
hat sich Denise Herrmann Wick heute
einen Podestplatz gesichert die
Olympiasiegerin landete im Sprint auf
dem dritten Platz einen Fehler am
Schießstand konnte sie mit der besten
Laufzeit wett machen Rang eins holte
sich die Schwedin Anna magnussson und
zweite wurde lind Person ebenfalls
Schweden
es war eine Attraktion und ein
Fremdkörper zugleich und natürlich haben
sich manche Hotelgäste gefragt ob der
gigantische Wassertank unter dem da in
der Lobby zum Aperitif gebeten wird auch
sicher hält
Alleinstellungsmerkmal für ein
Immobilienprojekt Aufmerksamkeit für ein
Kettenhotel das alle weniger unter
seinem Namen kennen sondern als das mit
dem Wassertank ein Unique Selling Point
wie die Marketing Leute sagen mit dem
sich Geld verdienen ließ aber eben auch
der Ort an dem 1500 Fische leben
lebten muss man leider sagen denn das
größte zylindrisch freistehende Aquarium
der Welt ist geplatzt und das Ganze
hätte noch viel schlimmer ausgehen
können Silvia blessmann
Fische gehören ins Meer dies bete
Verwüstung mitten in Berlin seine
riesengroße menschengemachte Katastrophe
so die Tierschutzorganisation Peter das
16 Meter hohe nun geborstene riesen
Aquarium war mit einer Million Liter
Wasser gefüllt hier schwammen 1500
Fische als Touristenattraktion die Wucht
der Explosion am frühen Morgen die ist
kurz die Erde beten dann schoss das
ganze viele Wasser durch die noch leere
hotel lobby das alles mit sich
das ist ein regelrechter Tsunami der
sich hier ergossen hat über die
hotelräumlichkeiten die anliegenden
Restaurants und wir können heute sagen
dass bei aller Zerstörung wir trotzdem
großes Glück gehabt haben denn es sind
nur zwei Menschen leicht verletzt worden
der Notruf kam früher um sechs viele der
ca 250 Hotelgäste wussten lange nicht
was da unten in der Lobby für ein Drama
passiert war alles zerstört überall tote
Fische und Scherben einen hotelannahme
gab es offenbar nicht ich habe dann
tatsächlich das ist irgendwie vielleicht
ein kurzes Erdbeben bin dann wieder
eingeschlafen und habe dann als der
Wecker ging gesehen dass die ganze
Straße gesperrt war dann googelt man
natürlich und dann habe ich das alles
gesehen der Aqua Dom stand hier 18 Jahre
war gerade im Sommer nach Renovierung
wieder eröffnet worden Taucher sollen
hier noch gestern gereinigt haben die
Eigentümer zeigen sich schriftlich
bestürzt über das Unglück was genau das
Becken zum Bersten brachte etwa
Materialermüdung oder
Konstruktionsfehler ist nun Gegenstand
der Ermittlungen
bei einem so riesigen Aquarium reicht
eine einzige Schwachstelle sagt ein
aquaristikexperte heute mit Blick auf
den enormen Wasserdruck der auf den
Wänden lastet und dann sagt er noch wenn
da ein Riss drin ist ist das Thema durch
etwa 500 kleinere Fischer aus anderen
Aquarien im Keller des Gebäudes hat die
Berliner Feuerwehr mittlerweile gerettet
und damit sagen wir jetzt danke für Ihr
Interesse heute und jetzt direkt weiter
hier im ZDF mit dem Politbarometer und
Matthias Fornoff tschüss
herzlich willkommen zum Politbarometer
gasknappheit Krieg und Inflation trotz
vieler Krisen und Sorgen ist die
Stimmung der deutschen zum Ende des
Jahres verhalten optimistisch das zeigen
die aktuellen Zahlen des politbarometers
obwohl die Einsparziele für Gas und
Strom derzeit nicht erreicht werden
machen sich die Deutschen mehrheitlich
keine großen Sorgen um die
Energiesicherheit
nur 29 Prozent erwarten ernsthafte
Probleme bei der Versorgung mit Erdgas
67% tun das nicht mit größeren
Stromausfällen rechnet nur knapp ein
Viertel der Befragten 73% erwarten
keinen Blackout
stark steigende Energiekosten bringen
derzeit viele Menschen in Bedrängnis die
Entlastungen durch die Bundesregierung
finden 44% der deutschen gerade richtig
fast ebenso vielen gehen sie aber nicht
weit genug die Ampelkoalition ist weiter
an vielen Fronten unter Druck wie wirkt
sich das auf die wählerstimmung aus wenn
am nächsten Sonntag Bundestagswahl wäre
käme die SPD auf 20 Prozent plus 1
cdu/csu 28% unverändert grüne 20 Prozent
Minus 2
fdp6 plus 1 AFD 15 + 1 Die Linke 5% -1
damit hätte die ampelregierung aus SPD
Grünen und FDP weiter keine
parlamentarische Mehrheit knapp reichen
würde es für eine unionsgeführte
Koalition mit den Grünen oder mit der
SPD
schauen wir auf die Top Ten der
wichtigsten Politikerinnen und Politiker
bewertet nach Sympathie und Leistung auf
der Skala von +5 bis -5
Alice Weidel ist weiter Schlusslicht
-2,7 verbessert davor Christine
Lambrecht -1,0 deutlich schlechter vor
ihr Sarah Wagenknecht minus 0,9 etwas
schlechter auf Rang 7 Friedrich Merz
minus 0,4 davor Markus Söder minus 0,1
beide unverändert Christian Lindner 0,0
verbessert Karl Lauterbach 0,1 etwas
besser auf Rang drei Olaf Scholz 0,6
verbessert vor ihm Robert Habeck 0,8
unverändert weiter an der Spitze Anna
Lena baerbock 0,9 etwas besser
angesichts anhaltender Kämpfe in der
Ukraine wird wieder über die Lieferung
moderner Kampfpanzer diskutiert
Bundeskanzler Scholz lehnt das weiter ab
und will einen deutschen Alleingang
vermeiden in der Bevölkerung aber hat
sich die Stimmung geändert
48 Prozent der Deutschen sagen die
Regierung sollte der Ukraine Kampfpanzer
zur Verfügung stellen 41 Prozent sind
dagegen unter allen partei-anhängern
gibt es Mehrheiten dafür außer bei den
Anhängern der AFD und der linke
aus Krisengebieten kommen zur Zeit
wieder viele Flüchtlinge zu uns das kann
Deutschland verkraften meint die
Mehrheit der Befragten
angesichts fehlender Fachkräfte will die
Bundesregierung den Zuzug für Ausländer
erleichtern und das stößt auf breite
Zustimmung
71% der Deutschen sind dafür und nur 23
Prozent dagegen das wäre ein wichtiger
Beitrag gegen den Fachkräftemangel sagen
72% der Befragten ein Viertel denkt das
nicht
in der corona-krise sind die Deutschen
eher zuversichtlich immer weniger
Menschen fürchten durch das Virus um
ihre Gesundheit derzeit so wenige wie
zuletzt zu Beginn der Pandemie der Ruf
nach strengen Vorsichtsmaßnahmen wird
zwar leiser eine knappe Mehrheit ist
aber für die maskenpflicht im
öffentlichen Nahverkehr
52 Prozent der Befragten sagen weiterhin
einen mund-nasen-schutz im öffentlichen
Nahverkehr soll Pflicht sein 44 Prozent
sind dagegen
Alleingänge einzelner Bundesländer sind
dabei unbeliebt 85% wünschen sich
einheitliche Regeln für ganz Deutschland
Bundeskanzler Scholz sprach diese Woche
von einem besonders schweren Jahr das zu
Ende geht die persönliche Bilanz der
meisten Deutschen fällt dennoch
überwiegend positiv aus
64% der deutschen sagen für mich war
2022 er ein gutes Jahr für ein Drittel
der Befragten war es eher schlecht jeder
vierte rechnet 2023 mit einer
Verbesserung seiner Lage 58 Prozent
erwarten keine große Veränderung und 15%
denken für sie wird es schlechter
in Bezug auf die eigene Wirtschaftslage
sind die Erwartungen etwas gedämpfter
und ein Drittel der Deutschen rechnet
mit finanziellen Einbußen im nächsten
Jahr die Hälfte glaubt dass ihre
finanzielle Lage in etwa gleich bleibt
das war unser Bericht über die Stimmung
im Land die Grafiken und alle
Informationen zu unseren Umfragen finden
Sie wie immer im ZDF Text ab Seite 165
in der ZDF heute App und auf ZDF
heute.de wie die repräsentativen
Umfragen der Forschungsgruppe Wahlen
zustande kommen Informationen zur
Methodik und zu den Qualitätsstandards
finden Sie unter politbarometer.zdf.de
vielen Dank für Ihr Interesse das
nächste Politbarometer gibt es dann im
neuen Jahr am 13 januar und nach dem
Wetter geht es hier weiter mit der
heute-show Ihnen noch einen entspannten
Abend auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter ja die Ruhe vor
dem Sturm herrschte erst einmal mit
diesem Hoch hier es bringt zwar
weiterhin eisige Nächte vor allem aber
auch Sonnenschein tagsüber und das
Sturmtief ist schon zu erkennen auf dem
Atlantik es wird mit warmer Luft die
Kälte aus Deutschland raus treiben und
sie ersetzen so dass es am Anfang der
Woche deutlich milder wird wir schauen
in die Nacht und im Südosten schneit es
noch das wird allmählich weniger Glätte
damit müssen sie weiterhin rechten auch
nach Westen nennen durch überfrierende
Nässe bei minus 15 Grad am Oberrhein und
minus drei Grad Richtung Nordsee morgen
dann viel Sonne wieder mal in der Mitte
und nach Westen wenn der Nebel
verschwindet sonst im Osten deutlich
dichtere Bewirkung insgesamt aber ein
trockener Tag und die Temperaturen dazu
höchste Werte mit -8 Grad im Süden
Deutschlands und 0 Grad nach Nordwesten
nennen das ist die Temperatur Spanne die
nächsten Tage am Sonntag ist es noch mal
knackig kalt teilweise nur -8 Grad als
Maximum bis 5 Grad dazu viel
Sonnenschein im Süden neblig und dann am
Montag wird es richtig ja richtig
durchwachsen Sturmtief mit Regen
gefrienem Regen und Temperaturen bis 11
Grad sind drin Dienstag sogar bis 14
Grad und damit ein schöner Abend